c'est la grande race rats c'est le piège
isabelle de revenus
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
enfin on ne peuvent être attendus par
cyril hanouna reçoit jamais un seul type
de fonctionnement gelé catllar il était
exceptionnel vraiment mon [ __ ] quel
bonheur j'ai toujours sa vie
non mais franchement c'est c'est
exceptionnel comment ça va chier
je te rends compte que vous avez vu que
j'étais magnifique qu'est ce tu attends
je me faire des images pour la semaine
prochaine
vas-y vas-y tu peux tu peux remettre là
tu peux renier fait plaisir on n'est pas
dans la caricature toits qu'il est
pakistanais des services voix elle
regarde quoi c'est un poulet aux
champignons champignons hallucinogènes
vous avez fait un choix de ma vie mais
je t'explique c'est un truc de ouf
tu mange du poulet ou pas j'étais comme
vous on apprend en plus vous avez
toujours le pool est chaud elle est un
peu inquiète sur les chantiers ainsi
qu'à des gens qui ont vu des trucs pas
vu moi j'ai rarement vu j'en ai vu une
seule une seule personne acceptée
personnes qui s'est pris pour une
abeille comme ça le cocktail sans alcool
cette vannetaise
alors je voulais vous parler du projet
en fait ça a cartonné quand on a fait le
matin le soir les 35 heures est en fait
je voudrais jean luc et toi en animateur
taintrux castro donc l'horoscope ensuite
tact au delà une rubrique people à 3
j'ai besoin d'aidé après bon il ya un
invité et ensuite voilà derrière tu vois
c'est un peu des astuces eu tout ça du
système d pour sa solution c'est ça le
champignon
c'est délicieux les attaques
ayant marche pas si mais moi j'ai en
fait il m'a mis du poulet ce que je
voulais que les champignons c'est moi je
mange pas de viande
ben moi je pense pas que ça va toucher
un petit peu mangé genre pas durant
alors qu'est ce tu dis l'émission sur
l'émission beaucoup des champignons tu
voudrais faire ou pas si on le fait à la
rentrée
moi ça m'intéresse moi sincèrement je
pense que le monde m'attend pas et que
les bornes mois mais tant pis si non
mais ça ne te voici le montage choisi
surtout je pense vraiment que le monde
attend qui que ce soit des canadiens à
la télé et j'ai eu lieu qu il est tout
rond d'alembert est très épicée
j'aime chez les confond en excuses et
moi mais c'est mon meilleur ami et faire
encore du tos cuse et là monsieur non
mais c'est la grammairienne confiance
excusez moi je travaille at elle confié
qu'il me compliquer c'est ton meilleur
ami nuit excusez moi vous appelez
françois ou pas du tout non ce n'est pas
ça mais pas françois weil c'est pas lui
c'est pas lui alors michel mais attends
moi je le connais pas ce gars là oui je
moi sur la connexion avec la je ne
connais pas bien donc je connais pas il
a même embrassé de la même teinte et
blizzard a tout pour elle que jamais
solidaires mais tout va bien pour notre
championnat n'est pas encore atteinte
[Musique]
[Rires]
jean luc tavernier
le gars qui était comme la famille de
françois il avait des corps non mais
sans déconner je veux pas les impôts
toilettes tout seul comme ça je trouve
bizarre dans le secteur peut pas
franchement d'un faux pas je suis sûr
que non mais tu étais un battant vas-y
n'allait pas bien mais voilà bien oui
toi oui toi un peu les statuts dit
bonsoir à qui je te jure je me tue
touche quoi david luiz à moi je te le
jure
mais non non mais ça me fait peur mais
tu me fais peur tu vois quoi bon soir
tu vois des gens que l'on ne voit pas
oui je prendre un peu l'air pourquoi on
leur fout là ouais ça alors non mais
alors questions prennent que tu penses
du projet non jean-luc toi tu es chaud
sur le projet pendant un mois mais
qu'est ce ça non mais qu'est ce t'as isa
sans déconner non ma chérie je te jure
je te couches ou mais quand tu vas me
confondre que jean-luc mois jean-luc et
benjamin autre moitié des finesses même
et autres gros lourdaud là ne veut pas
qu'on parle de moi j'ai un gros mois
chez un monsieur qui ont un peu de
respect pour finir non mais déjà on va
dans les toilettes andy joie des gens là
ils croient que c'est son meilleur ami
ce pas du tout son meilleur ami
excusez-moi mari devait me confondre
avec quelqu'un c'est pas possible tu te
fout de notre gueule ou quoi
isabelle dans son arrêté que tu me fais
peur tu veux qu'on se revoit demain non
demandées excusez moi un pape et notre
serveur c'est inquiétant quand même
temps on va payer je vais y aller tu me
tues moi non mais je vais payer au royal
et beauté normal alors parce que j'ai
pas normal moi il doit s'il est normal
ce qui t'arrive
non mais c'est sûr que tu fais de
réaction aux jambes est normal leurs
champignons à la manger 10 dans le
métier je te jure t grave non mais là tu
me plais vraiment peur les plus sûres
monsieur oui bien sûr on va prendre
l'addition sur l'addition croyez-le ou
non mais pas de rappeler le patron d
apple le patron mais de quoi au juste à
vue je me suis avec les petites poignées
d'amour
ça vaut le teaser à leur voltigeur je te
jure que non j'ai toujours connu j'ai
appelé médecin je vois plein de sens et
je refais un médecin excusez moi excusez
moi monsieur vous dérange vous non mais
parce qu'on a un problème avec la dame
je crois qu'elle est malade
vous l'avez vu comment le serveur là on
lui a demandé nos plats quoi parce qu'au
bout d'un moment ça fait une demi heure
qu'on est la nature pas manger mais
manger modérés n'ont pas dit non mais ce
qu'elle voit le serveur mujdza binôme il
voulait qu'on se déshabille nous gros
coup dur pour le mans en est ils sont
les conneries tu voi le mec à point je
suis appelé les réseaux chefs voir ce
qu'il s'est attaqué champignons s'il
vous plaît on peut avoir le chef s'il
vous plaît mais personne n'est venu
exigeant qu'est ce qui se passe au soir
chef qu'est le problème
alors chers seront donc on a regardé
sous son nom mais qu'est ce que j'ai
fait quoi elle a mangé les ailes à moi
j'ai plus les champignons à lui seul
nous arrive de temps en temps non mais
et qui se passe ça vous à nous de temps
en temps c'est des champignons
hallucinogènes c'est ça oui c'est ça je
reviens tout choper le médecin des
médecins rappelle médecins merci pour
pour être lui faire mal un champignon
non mais non est ce que tu te sens bien
julien lepers mais je prends à plaire
est ce qu'on peut leur montrer combien
de temps cette durée faits non mais je
te jure que c'est ça vient vertueux et
on voit la mer
sans déconner tu deviens folle est sûre
on va prendre un peu l'air bien on a
appelé le médecin tu te sens mieux mais
je me sens très bien
art et isa sans déconner ma chérie
arrête parce que tu es en train de faire
passer le projet en suivant dans ce
restaurant aujourd'hui est mis en branle
un peu pâlotte entrer l'art ancien jeu
du témoin on l'a rentrer merci docteur
français elle a mangé des champignons
hallucinogènes
entrée qu'est-ce-qui armes possibles qui
s'était encore vu non mais dis moi très
bien mais quelle roue mais émet cas pas
maintenant étant dit l'auteur vous
étendez les piles et de lever les gens
il n'ya pas de françois je croyais que
c'est qu'il ne sait pas aller pas bien
la jama castaldi c'est quand même
incroyable continuer c'est pas
désagréable que ça devient un peu obsédé
comme un buteur est incroyable c'est
vous allez dites très fort la grande
race rare 20 500 la grande brasserie la
grande dame ça allait encore là beaucoup
mangent la grande race 1
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bravo usa bat j
[Applaudissements]